One of the things that became super clear
during the last administration was that
so many of the things that the right accused
the left of doing, they were actually guilty of
themselves. And we have a word for this. This is
projection. You project onto someone else things
about you. You accuse others of doing things
that you were doing. And one of those things
was that the left is rooting against America. And
this applied in a whole bunch of different ways.
Don Jr., for example, famously said a couple
months into coronavirus. I don't remember remember
exactly when it was kind of I think in that.
Third quarter of twenty twenty, Don Jr. said the
left and Democrats are rooting against the U.S.
on covid Democrats want people to die of covid
to make Donald Trump look bad. And of course, it
was completely untrue. There was no evidence of
that. But they continue to insist. They also would
talk about, oh, the left is rooting for Russia,
the left is rooting for China, or the left is
rooting for Europe or whatever the case may be.
Things have now come full circle. And in the
developing kerfuffle between President Joe
Biden and Russian President Vladimir Putin, we're
going to talk about that more on the bonus show.
Fox News and Republicans and right wingers
are openly rooting for Vladimir Putin. Now,
is that patriotism when they say America first,
when they say pro America, is this what they're
talking about, openly rooting for Vladimir Putin?
This started when Joe Biden referred to Vladimir
Putin as a killer last week. And then Vladimir
Putin challenged Joe Biden to a debate. Now, why
foreign leaders would debate and people wouldn't
say that doesn't make sense. We'll talk about in a
little bit. But let's look at some clips. They're
all rooting against the United States here. Take a
look at this first clip of Fox News propagandist
Sean Hannity. Who does he sound like he's
behind? Is he real rallying behind the American
president here? No, it doesn't sound like it.
Now, the question is this. Why would
Vladimir Putin immediately call
for a debate with Joe Biden? No time to prepare.
What have I been saying? What if some of us have
the American people saying the media mob in
this country, they protect all things radical
socialist Joe Biden and his administration.
Hannity defending Putin, challenging Biden to
a debate. If it were Trump challenged by a foreign
leader, Hannity would say, were the United States.
Nobody challenges us. No American president needs
to debate any foreign leader. We do whatever
the hell we want. Different situation right
now. Here's Republican Congressman Matt Gates
straight up saying this debate
would be all Putin if it happened.
Putin and Biden, it would not end like Rocky
for I don't think the American would prevail.
Here's Fox anchor Harris Faulkner.
Similar attitude, saying, of course,
Putin is going to challenge Biden because
Biden hasn't even done a press conference.
But Biden, by the way, doing a press
conference Thursday, which I will be
covering live. Here's Harris Faulkner.
I can't help but think, Katie, I just a
quick follow up with you, that this isn't also
the determination that how dare America talk to
us about free speech when their own president
won't go live with free media? Like how? Well,
it does make us look like we're hypocritical.
So there are two layers of hypocrisy here.
First is the idea that this is as simple as Putin
vs. Biden on rhetorical skills and none of them
want to mention the dramatically authoritarian
nature of Putin, the poisonings, the killings,
the fact that Putin is accurately described as a
killer by Joe Biden. They're silent on that. They
won't even concede. None of them are saying maybe
Putin would win a debate. But Joe Biden is right.
Putin is a killer. But maybe the debate would
go Putin's way. They won't even say that. They
don't even acknowledge the accurate critique of
Putin by Joe Biden acknowledging that doesn't
mean we go to war with Russia. I don't want
a war with Russia. I don't know anyone who
wants a war with Russia. But then here is the
crowd that for years and years during Bush,
during Trump, they say we are patriots and we
stand behind the president, period. It's always
America first, never second or third or anything.
And here they are just saying, yeah, Putin, Putin,
Putin. No criticism of Putin, not even saying
Biden's right, even if he's not a good debater.
Biden is right. Putin is a killer. These people
are disgusting, but they're also hypocrites. And
we knew both of those things all along. Now, one
last thing. I mentioned this earlier, when has
an American president ever debated a foreign
president in particular at the demand of the
foreign leader? What and what I mean by that is
why are they even entertaining this on the facts?
They ran out of things about Dr. Seuss. I guess
if any foreign leader had challenged Trump to
a debate, they'd be saying an American president
owes nothing to other world leaders. No American
president should devote a second of their time
debating another world leader. The goalposts
aren't even in the same stadium when the president
is a Democrat, as is Joe Biden. So we're going to
get the press conference. I'm as interested as
anybody else to see Joe Biden answer questions
from the press in a more extended format.
That'll be Thursday. Don't know the time yet,
but I will be covering it live on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook. I hope you'll join me for that. And
between now and then, in the 72 hours that remain
before Joe Biden's press conference, we will
continue tracking what it used to be, Dr. Seuss
24/7. Now it's Biden versus Putin 24/7 on Fox News